as of today most of the patients are not
looking at cannabis as something to get
high from they're looking at cannabis as
a medicine
to get their pain to get really from
their pain
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel at stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be doing a deep dive into the
israeli cannabis
market meet omar zergachia cannabis and
tech entrepreneur
with 15 years of cross-sector experience
and founding managing and directing
private and public companies in the tech
and cannabis industries
omer has been leading m a processes
global strategic partnerships and deal
making worldwide
oma has also been teaching as a senior
lecturer in various academic institutes
both for computer science and for
behavioral sciences with a
specialization
in cannabis welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you thank you how you doing happy
to be here pretty good
you ready to talk about cannabis yeah
let's go but you don't consume cannabis
but you're one of the leading figures in
the israeli system for cannabis
how does that work well so in israel
basically cannabis
is as of today is for medical purposes
pharmaceutical purposes
uh that's the people that we're serving
are the patients in israel
and fortunately i am not one of them i'm
pretty healthy so i don't need to
consume cannabis
in order to make my uh health better
for other reasons such as the
recreational uh
sphere the recreational world i'm a
total believer that
it gives joy to many uh people i'm not
there
and and i believe that the israeli
market as we see it
today is going to move forward and
uh make recreational cannabis legal
in the next couple of months
years from now so i'm a huge believer in
cannabis when it comes to the medical
sphere and there again fortunately
i have the privilege to serve and to
provide cannabis to those patients that
it gives
a lot of relief and help to their pains
both physically
and uh um emotionally now if we were to
have if i were to do this podcast even
five or seven years ago
it probably would have been really
difficult for me to have somebody
talking about cannabis on a social media
platform
what happened in this last three four
five years that
really changed the way and allows me to
also feel very comfortable
talking to an expert in cannabis on my
social media
so a lot of happened like if we look at
again at the israeli market but also
uh the the global market five years ago
israel had only eight players in the
game
eight cultivators that uh grew cannabis
and provided it to patients uh
not in the manner we're not in the
manner we know today if we look
globally so we had states in the us that
provided it
we had canada that provided it but it
wasn't the boom
that we experiencing today i think that
several verticals have worked their way
up
they were the regulation first that
came to realize that cannabis is
a pharmaceutical product and when i say
the the regulation not everywhere still
today just take the us
the fda does not approve cannabis even
if you have
30 something states in the us that
approve cannabis
the fda the federal government is not
approving it yet
so although we had a huge leap of
faith and also the regulations in israel
in canada in germany lately in france
and other countries we haven't uh
uh been we haven't saw it
on on every uh country in the western
world but
what do we learn from seeing different
regulatory
organizations you know allowing cannabis
to be used
either for recreational use or better
for medical use what happened
you know to society for what can we see
already as sort of a trend looking
forward
so first of all we need to understand
that cannabis is here before us
cannabis is one of the ancient uh crops
uh
in the in in the world that we know of
it suffered uh in the 20th century
from a bedrock bad reputation
that brought it to be something that is
illegal
um like a hundred years ago or not a
hundred but 80 years ago hollywood
were against cannabis okay nixon
was against cannabis and uh and his
government
uh but as of today we see that cannabis
got to the pharmacies through the
uh through the door and today it's being
prescribed
and israel is a very good example for
that
we're seeing something very interesting
that cannabis for my opinion
is the the first to come meaning we see
a botanical
uh substance something we grow that
the western world for years uh took it
very hard to understand that it has
a lot of benefits that we cannot really
understand what's behind them meaning
cannabis
has hundreds of of active materials
as of today in israel and in europe when
we look at cannabis we look at thc we
look at cbd
sometimes at cbn and maybe two other
cannabinoids
but we have hundreds more the fda
the the western medicine doesn't know
how to work with
hundreds of molecules it knows how to
work with a single
molecule and then you do the test the
clinical test you prove that it's safe
you prove that you can understand
exactly who can consume it how when etc
and then they improve it cannabis is not
the same
the reason cannabis got into the
pharmacies is not because of the
clinical data
you need to understand cannabis is in
that sense one of a kind last time
and and don't get me on that but i'm
pretty sure i'm i'm pretty sure it's
true
less time than the drug got into
pharmacies
without clinical evidence was something
like 110
years ago wow so cannabis did that
without any clinical tests
why because the population
decided because it was good for them
because some of the countries such as
israel
such as denmark decided to do a pilot
period
saying okay let's do a pilot period of
two years for example
let's provide specific patients with
cannabis
let's provide specific companies with
the license
to uh cultivate cannabis and let's see
how it works
right there's something agent ancient
about cannabis that suddenly some of the
western countries
decided to embrace and say okay if it
worked for hundreds of years thousands
of years
and we and it was okay let's start
examining
that not in the clinical fda
path but in a different path and
when i'm looking at the future i hope as
i
mentioned before that cannabis is the
first one to come
and i hope and believe that the other
botanical substances
will be uh here to follow and that the
regulation that
is experiencing a very i believe good
experience with cannabis
will do the same with other substances
right and so if you're looking today the
israeli ecosystem and you're looking at
your part in it
as an entrepreneur in secret system what
is that even like so
right now we're seeing we're seeing
different startups emerge and like in
the cannabis world and leveraging
technology to go and either optimize the
growing or
or better transparency what is it like
entering as an entrepreneur to the
cannabis world and tell me a little bit
about your own journey there
so it's very interesting as always um
so i began my journey in the cannabis
world where it was the old regulation
the old regulation
was eight players that basically
cultivated
manufacture and provided patients with
cannabis in a direct kind of way you had
only two anchors you had the cultivator
and you had
the patient and that was the connection
you did everything as a cultivator
nowadays since the new regulation got
into
a place this value chain was divided
into five links
you have the breeder the breeding
facility you have the cultivation
facility
you have the manufacturing facility you
have the distribution
uh facility and you have the pharmacy
and those five
links are connected in order to provide
the patient
with a pharmaceutical product
so that's the story behind the
regulation in like 20 seconds
for me as an entrepreneur i got in from
the financial aspect
i i have a very good and long time
connection
and with one of israel's uh eighth
first cannabis companies candock and
i got in uh uh back in the end of uh
and that led me to uh to a
process that took almost uh two years of
taking cando public
and basically becoming the first uh uh
cannabis israeli cannabis lp uh to be
public on the israeli stock exchange
kandak is now
uh did the spec as well and is about to
become a public on nasdaq as well
taking a company that was the smallest
company the smallest cannabis company in
the industry
to be as of today one of the biggest i
believe it's the
the largest the leading cannabis company
in israel so it was kind of it was it
was a hell of a journey
uh doing that and again i came not from
the
ideology ideology i
ideal world of cannabis as the savior of
this
world that is a a problem fixer
that saw a lot of potential in the
company and in the market
and again fortunately probably the word
that i'm saying the most
fortunately i had the privilege to uh to
succeed with it
and so if we're looking now at the
cannabis world of where it is today
and looking a little bit into the future
what are what are we observing
what what trends how is it going to
affect us as consumers either medically
or recreationally
you know economically but also just in
terms of regulations and how we perceive
cannabis and how it's going to be
integrated into into our daily lives
so first of all it's as of today and i
believe it's going to be the same for
the next few years it's a matter of
geography first of all it depends where
you live
if it's the us if it's canada it's
germany if it's israel and every
uh uh geography has its own rules
as we see it today again i'm taking the
israeli market as uh
as a as a point of view as we see it
today we see
uh first of all an increase of the usage
from the
patient side uh the age of our patients
using cannabis is getting higher the
reason is
that today cannabis is has a better
reputation than it had before
and even before the age the average age
was for example
40 we see it today more closer to 50.
okay
so that's very interesting it's a big
say because you're saying that the older
generations that are coming in with
these preconceived notions of what
cannabis is
that that is showing a dramatic shift in
our understanding of society
exactly it's it's it as of today
most of the patients are not looking at
cannabis as something to get
high from they're looking at cannabis as
a medicine
to get their pain to get really from
their pain
so that's one it's very interesting to
see that the second thing
uh uh we see is the element of money
getting into the industry
because of all the uh companies that got
in
and all the money that got got in a lot
from the public sphere
we see a lot of money going into new
products going into new streams going
into new researches and and because of
that
we see a bigger variety of products
a bigger variety of strains and if i'm
taking
uh a leap forward of like let's say five
years
i believe we'll see also a lot more
technologies in it
and when i say technologies i mean even
in the products
itself like the the the two major
elements that
uh we see in cannabis one is the way we
consume it
as of today still seventy percent of the
global market
are using cannabis food joints
that's not the most medicinal kind of
way to use it right
so we see a lot of products that are
being developed
today that are being developed in order
to provide
doctors with the possibility to tell
their patients listen
take it as you take any other medicine
whether it's a gel capsule but whether
it's a patch
or a spray so we see that the second
element
is an element called bioavailability one
of the things we see with cannabis is
that once you consume it
you don't consume 100 of what you're
getting into your body
a lot of elements once you put it
sublingual
once you uh swallow it are basically
being uh
are disappearing because of your body
so we believe that through technology we
can sort of
coach the product you're taking in order
for your body
to to to take more out of this product
so those two verticals are tech
technology verdict right
and we see more and more companies
getting into those verticals so that's
very interesting now
what is the barrier for for young
entrepreneurs to come and say listen
there's this great market here
there's a lot of innovation to be done
we can leverage our
our skills either in biology or maybe in
computational biology or
ai to help work in this market is there
still this psychological barrier of i
don't want to
i don't want to be known as a cannabis
entrepreneur
is there still a barrier of some sort so
i think that in our generation and
younger generation the barrier has
passed but i do think that there is a a
gap of knowledge
two years ago my brother and i oi
that he's my partner both in kandoki was
kandok ceo
and today we're heading a new company
we open up uh a degree
a ba degree in uh uh the israeli
valley uh college in israel and this
degree basically
uh is trying to take
a lot of elements from the cannabis
world and and provide it to students
because we
recognize that there is a very big gap
between what we know as a part of the
industry
and what the world knows even if he
wants to know
so this ba allows students to get
into into the cannabis industry from
the academia side and that's super
super important i believe today that
if you're trying to get into the
cannabis world
and you want to open up a new business
first of all you need to study
whether it's the va whether it's from
the internet
meeting people from the industry
understanding what are the gaps every
year
every quarter every five years whatever
this is a very hectic
industry so you need every
point of time to understand what is
lacking or where is the potential for
example in 2018
when we took canada public the main gap
was cultivation i won't say that's the
main gap today
it's a different one so recognize the
gap
and get into it but only after you have
the knowledge
to uh what's the regulation about it
what are the
uh target audience in your uh case what
is existing in this sphere in the world
in canada in the us
in europe etc and once you have that in
line
i believe that there is a lot to do
because cannabis
is a very old product but a very
new industry like legal industry
the potential is huge both on the
product side and the geographical side
so once you understand that you have a
lot of room to act
i love it oh man thank you so much i
have a few more questions before i do
before there you go
but they're about oh man i'm not about
cannabis and i want to take you back to
your childhood what what really
fascinated you as a kid
as you were going around the world what
what
what was going through your mind um i
think
i think cables and computers and some
everything that was connected into
technology that i could
like uh break apart uh put cables
and put cables out understanding what
moves
uh different elements in it i think that
was amazing
as a geek kid was the most uh free
thing and today what inspires you people
definitely people i know it's a cliche
but definitely people knowing
new people listening to their stories
taking
out from their stories the thing that
suits me people
everywhere amazing and what are three
words
or two or four that you would use to
describe yourself
myself yourself well uh
yeah in hebrew we have a saying
translated later uh it's hard to
describe myself
um but i would uh
say hopefully i would say a curiosity
uh kindness and
something i'm working on lately a lot
[Music]
patience
thank you amazing thank you so much
you